and wow okay samsung
i gotta say props to you guys hey guys
it's max we just got in the brand new
galaxy book pro from samsung and you can
pick one of these up for 999 dollars
with an oled display and the rest of the
specs and the design seems like it's
going to be super competitive
with the m1 macbook air so today we're
going to test out everything from the
display
the webcam microphones keyboards
trackpads along with
performance and we actually have some
brand new
tests uh that are gonna be very exciting
and might show some major differences
between
the actual real world usage that we've
been experiencing so first off
my impression this thing is definitely
light it kind of reminds me geez the
kind reminds me of the 12
inch retina macbook and the weight on
this thing
comes in at 2.2 pounds
compared to 2.8 pounds for the macbook
air you could definitely tell the
difference in your hand
i never thought i would say this but the
macbook air actually feels heavy right
now
compared to this thing and what's weird
is that even though it was so
lightweight
it does not feel cheap the aluminum
feels nice
the body here feels solid as well i
remember the lg
gram that was lightweight but it
definitely felt cheap so
overall so far i'm impressed and let's
look at these ports this is crazy look
at this hdmi port that actually has the
bottom cut
out in order for it to fit and then of
course we have a couple usb type cs one
is thunderbolt 4
and on the other side we have a usb type
a port
also with the bottom cut out uh who says
that you can't fit
full-size ports in such a small machine
samsung just proved apple
wrong we have a headphone jack and a
micro sd card slot compared to
just two usbc ports as far as thickness
they are quite similar
the macbook air slightly thinner at the
wedge side
and then a little bit thicker on the
back i honestly feel like samsung should
have called this the galaxy book air if
they're gonna copy that kind of a naming
scheme
because it is tiny and one thing i'm
noticing is this thing is a fingerprint
magnet i swear my fingers are not that
dirty or oily but this thing picks up
everything so now let's go ahead and do
a hinge test
all right and wow i actually was not
expecting that
i thought because this thing is so
lightweight it would just flop around
but they balance that pretty well
and we have the intel evo logo which is
crooked that really bugs me and we have
an energy star logo
which is very interesting if this intel
processor is an energy star i wonder
what the m1 is
in relation to that you guys let me know
uh what you think this should be called
down in the comment section below
let's go ahead and power up this machine
and obviously you guys could see
we definitely have some difference the
display is a lot shorter it is a 16x9
display
but we will be testing out this oled
screen here in just a little bit
and one thing i want to mention to you
guys is that along with this test
we are going to do another video where
we're going to run windows 10
with parallels on the m1 macbook air and
compare the real world performance
compared to buying an actual windows
laptop you guys hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to see that
video
you guys can also help us reach 1
million subscribers before the end of
the year which is our goal
we would really appreciate it so it
looks like it actually came dead out of
the box which is super frustrating
that doesn't happen with max so we're
gonna go ahead and plug this thing in
and i guess we're gonna have to
switch it to the opposite side that way
it can be plugged in and charging all
right we are up and rolling and both of
these have
a fingerprint scanner to log in so they
are even
i do miss the windows hello sign in
which i
love and it's awesome but at least these
are similar
now let's go ahead and before we get
into the keyboards and track pads
i don't see any speakers here this
machine weighs 2.2 pounds
so i'm really curious how does the sound
quality compare
and guys i need your honest opinion
when we told you guys we're gonna stop
using this song so many of you guys said
no
keep it we love it and then we go back
and people are complaining saying no
find something else so we need to hear
your opinions and please
go and suggest some songs that are no
copyright that we can use
for this test and the one with the most
upvotes we will go for
[Music]
all right guys i don't even have to ask
for you to comment below
there's no comparison the samsung is
quieter a lot quieter it's a lot more
flat sounding compared to this loud rich
experience with great highs
great bass if you're gonna watch movies
or listen to music with the built-in
speakers
it's the macbook air all the way and now
let's compare the keyboard and the
trackpad i have been typing a bit
as i was downloading programs that we
are going to test
and the keyboard is about average it
does feel a little bit springy and it's
not too loud which is good
but the overall feel doesn't compare
with some of the other windows laptops
and of course the magic keyboard and the
macbook air and with that
trackpad of course uh our force touch
trackpad
it's amazing it there's no complaints
there's no comparison
where this thing it is your standard
diving board design and the clickiness
there's a big difference between the top
and the bottom it definitely is
i would say probably about average maybe
slightly below average
and now let's talk about the displays
and this is where the galaxy book pro
should shine with this oled panel but
first
let's talk about resolutions in the
aspect ratio
so this is a 16x9 display which is why
we see
more vertical space here and at the
bottom this also has this large chin
because of that and maybe samsung is
trying to go for that chin look just
like the new
imax so maybe that's getting popular but
personally i love having a 16 by 10
display
for productivity with the screen size
and even better a 3x2 a lot of windows
laptop companies are switching to that
samsung is sticking with 16 by nine
now the other thing that stands out to
me is the sharpness or the detail i can
clearly see with all this text
that it is not as sharp as apple's 218
pixels per inch screen here we have
about 160 so
even though it's oled it just doesn't
look sharp now the benefit is battery
life and we'll talk about that in just a
bit
now a huge benefit for oled displays are
the
rich deep black colors where we have
pure black
and just nice contrast so i opened up a
trailer right here
and looking at it the weird thing is
that the contrast
is actually better on the macbook air
even though it has a standard
lcd panel now colors are a little bit
more vibrant
on the oled screen but the actual blacks
they are more gray than the lcd screen
and then with that it's also more
reflective of course the chin here is
really shiny
but the actual screen itself is more
reflective as well
and when you add in that lower
resolution that really has me thinking
is it worth using an
oled display when you can have an lcd
that looks better of course apple
doesn't make
the screens here i know lg and samsung
make screens for
apple so that is just really surprising
and now it's compared to microphones and
the webcams this is the quality that you
get from the samsung we do have
two microphones that are facing me right
on top of the screen which is great
but you guys will be able to judge the
video and the microphone quality for
yourselves and this is the webcam and
microphone quality
from the macbook air so go ahead and let
me know down in the comment section
which one looked better and which one
sounded better to you
and now let's get into our performance
test we do have some new testing
and i'm excited to run these because we
are gonna have this laptop plugged in
for full performance we'll also check it
unplugged with
geekbench and as i start the cpu test
here i do have to say that we do not
have the 999 dollar base model i wanted
to order that
but for some reason samsung's only
shipping that out later so this is the
upgraded i7
so you get the better chip compared to
m1 both do have eight gigs of ram
all right guys we have a result and this
is actually
probably the highest single core score
that i have seen multi-core score is
also
very good but of course the m1 beats it
out even though this is a base macbook
compared to the higher end i7 of course
that is
plugged in now one thing i want to
mention is that the i5
also scores very very similarly to the
i7
in our testing so if you want to buy one
of these pick up at the 999 dollar
version i wouldn't spend
the extra money now i also want to
mention that i did hear the fan spin up
pretty early on in this test which was
interesting
and now i want to run run test unplugged
because they're saying energy
star on here let's see if they're trying
to preserve so much energy that the
performance is just going to fall
flat on its face we will give it the
best performance option here
and let's run that again all right the
fan has been
running meaning that we are getting good
performance so it's almost done
let's see what we get and wow okay
samsung i gotta say props to you guys
the score is almost identical let's go
back right here 1550
to 1512 and the multi-core score it
actually went up a little bit and that
is
so refreshing to see that compared to
the last few windows laptops that we
have
tested so energy star can i peel this
sticker off
i'm glad it's not energy star i'm glad
it's using more power
to give you full performance on battery
that's awesome
and now let's take a look at the
graphics we are running vulkan
in geekbench here compared to metal i
also have
another really great graphics test
coming up right after this
but let's see how these stack up all
right and wow
i cannot believe that samsung is pulling
this off in a machine
that weighs two pounds and is this slim
in light what are you guys doing dell
and whoever else is out there that we
reviewed lg
and much thicker machines where we're
getting this level of performance so
we have basically sixteen thousand
fifteen thousand nine eleven compared to
ninety thousand
so the m1 macbook air is about twenty
percent faster in terms of
graphics but now let's go ahead and
close this and see how that applies in
the real world now we're gonna test out
the brand new 3d mark
wildlife cross platform test that is
optimized for metal it does look
different the way it tests on the
systems but
we have confirmed it and the results
stack up and it is designed for these
new apple silicon m1 chips
and we have our results here and this is
where we have
a much bigger difference well we have
about 50 percent higher score or better
frame rate
for the m1 macbook air and that just
shows how much optimization apple has
made
in terms of gaming they have a bunch of
special techniques that they're using
to maximize the fps so we have 50
difference compared to only
20 when we tested out geekbench and now
let's get into our real world tests
i have adobe lightroom opened up right
here which is now
optimized for the m1 and i'm going to do
this a little bit differently this time
some of you guys asked to use the spot
healing brush
because that usually lags for you guys
and it's not something we've tested
before
so let's go ahead and click at the same
time
and that actually was faster
or maybe just didn't do a good job i
don't know obviously didn't get healed
here here got healed
let's try that one more time all right i
have a different photo here let's try
that again in a tougher spot
okay it is fairly close and as far as
responsiveness if we're zooming in
wow we're actually getting choppiness on
the samsung where the m1 is perfectly
smooth
and let's just go ahead and switch
through a few of these photos these are
large raw photos with a bunch of
corrections
and it's pretty much hit or miss
sometimes the same sometimes one or the
other is faster
and now let's go ahead and select all
these images and we're going to export
all
50. looks like so far we're about on par
and it's interesting to see how much
wattage this thing is using it actually
kicked down it was at 26 watts
and that's using both the cpu and a lot
of the gpu as well so it looks like
lightroom
is fairly well optimized and after a bit
it does look like the wattage goes down
to get the temperature down it was a
little over 90 degrees celsius at first
now it's hovering right at 85 which
seems like that's exactly where samsung
wants it
whereas our macbook air is running at 93
94 degrees celsius now
more than halfway through of course it
is fanless so it's completely silent
whereas this samsung even though it's
powerful a lot of times even we're not
doing anything we hear the fan
spinning up and running to keep it cool
no way is a samsung
actually going to beat out the m1 in an
optimized app
and bam it actually beat out the m1 the
m1 is close
this is what happens when you have
really good performance and you're not
limiting the performance of your laptop
like a lot of others are doing
and without of course we are plugged in
this time but samsung i saw they have
their own mode
uh called samsung mode instead of
balance which the fans are spinning up
but the performance is good alright we
are done there
so finally the m1 chip has been beat
at least in this test we have four
minutes in one second
for the samsung galaxy book pro compared
to 4 minutes and 25 seconds for the m1
now let's go ahead and close this and we
are going to head into
photoshop and look at that look at that
desktop on both
adobe said that this version of
photoshop is also optimized for
apple silicon and the first test that i
want to do
is their new super resolution
now we did this with uh the different
computer the huawei
unplugged on battery and it was way
slower dramatically slower
so i'm really curious now that the
samsung has beat this out
in lightroom how will this compare all
right there
bam we just finished that was
way faster than the huawei on battery
power dramatically faster
it took 53 seconds to do this to
quadruple the resolution use the ai
algorithm but
our m1 macbook air and if you guys
didn't see that video go ahead and pause
and just vote down in the
comment section tell us how long you
think this took with the m1
it took 13 seconds compared to
53 seconds and that just shows the power
of the machine learning that is built in
that is used
for things like this and now we are
going to do an hdr
test so i have all these images over
here i'm going to select
all of them and we're going to merge to
hdr the m1 just finished took a minute
and 37 seconds
but here we are sitting around and
waiting
oh bam it just got done took five
minutes and 13 seconds
compared to a minute and 37 seconds so
who knows maybe machine learning
is actually being used for hdr now and
now for our last test we're going to
take a look at video editing
premiere pro is still in beta for m1 but
there was just an update
and since this machine has been so
powerful i want to see
how it can compare to the previous
laptops that we tested
that kind of suck for video editing so
right now we're playing back
i have dog ears enabled meaning that i
can see the frame right here
oh and actually it set the default to
half quality all right i actually
thought it was doing great there let's
check it back again
we'll give it a chance all right so yep
there we go we are getting a stuttery
mess playing back at
7 8 10 13 12 frames per second about
half the quality
but you can play back if you lower it
down whereas with the m1
it is playing back perfectly at 24
frames per second at full quality with
the effects applied
film grading applied all of that so it
looks like when you're combining cpu
and gpu definitely the m1 is coming
ahead of course
we're gonna go ahead and export this
five minute project so it looks like
adobe has actually
increased the performance for m1 it's
taken about seven minutes estimated time
for this five minute project
used to be from nine minutes to 12
minutes so they keep making it faster
on the samsung we're getting roughly 12
minutes total time
for the estimate and these are fairly
close so it looks like as far as video
editing performance this is similar to
say like a dell xps
um and maybe the microsoft surface
laptop for
very similar performance but uh the m1
is ahead
getting you know close to twice as fast
now for video editing
so what is our final verdict well the
first thing that shocked me
is how lightweight this machine is first
i thought it was 2.2 pounds then it
actually is
just under two what i found online and
with that
thinness and lightness the performance
is beating out
much bigger and heavier ultrabooks that
we've tested and unplugged it also
performed great
now of course it has that ole display
the contrast it isn't as good as i hoped
but i think that might just be the
reflectivity layer
whereas apple has a really great one
that they use
and it actually beat the macbook out in
some tests so
overall the m1 is still faster
especially for video editing
but if you're doing regular use and you
want to get great performance
unplugged the samsung does offer that
and then
you can actually buy one for 9.99 with
the i5 that is not much slower
and you still get the same machine same
ports same
display so overall if you're looking for
a windows laptop
that can keep up with an m1 at least for
some of those photo tasks and web
browsing
it's going to give you great performance
for a great price this definitely is a
good option and it definitely
surprised us but of course with the m1
the speakers are a lot better the
display is better i like the 16 by 10
aspect ratio
keyboard trackpad is better video
editing performance is better as well in
the battery life
real world usable battery life that is
better as well
so there you guys go we'll leave links
in the video description you can
actually pick one up right now for
900 bucks which is a killer price
and if you guys want to see another
video of us comparing this machine with
windows 10
against the m1 running parallels running
windows 10 make sure you guys click that
circle above to subscribe
and help us reach our goal of 1 million
subs by the end of this year that would
be awesome
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]